Good morning, Hank. It's Friday August 29th
and since I know you don't like to watch the news,
I'm now going to tell you everything that I think you need to know about
presumptive Republican vice presidential nominee, Sarah Palin
Pahlin? I don't even know how to say her name I'm so surprised.
[Vlogbrothers theme]
Part 1: Sarah Palin is the 44-year-old governor of the great state of Alaska.
She's been the governor of Alaska for just under 2 years.
Before that she was the head of the city council in Wasilla, Alaska...
A town name I might be mispronouncing even though I've been there several times.
Number 2: On all of the social issues that are important to the Republican base
she is reliably conservative.
She's strongly pro-life, anti-gay marriage, and a life-long member of the
National Rifle Association
In fact, she is a moose hunter.
That sounds like a euphemism for something, but it's not
She actually hunts moose.
Number 3: In what might be the most politically corrupt state in the U.S.
She has a reputation for being strongly anti-corruption.
Hank, I briefly lived in Alaska and let me tell you from
experience Alaska has about as many
uncorrupt politicians as it has
pleasant winter days
so that's certainly a vote in her
favor. Another vote in her favor would be
thing 4. She's married to a
commercial fisherman
now, Hank, I wasn't able to find any
pictures of Sarah Palin's husband on
the internet but I'm hoping that he
looks like the sailor from The Simpsons.
Thing 5: She has a kid named Track.
That's a political liability.
Who's joined the Army and is going to Iraq. That's a political asset.
It's like McCain was saying, "Joe Biden I
see your son who's going to Iraq and I
raise you an Alaskan infantryman named
Track."
Oh, also, I forgot to mention Sarah
Palin's husband is a semi-professional
snowmobiler
Really. He races snowmobiles.
Thing 6: She has absolutely no foreign
policy experience.
Now, of course, the McCain camp's going to say
that it doesn't matter that she doesn't
have foreign policy experience because
McCain has loads of foreign policy
experience.
Which is fine. Just so long as McCain is
you know, alive. Which I thought was kinda
why you picked a vice president but
anyway.
Thing 7: She's been a very Alaska-centric governor.
You know there's some governors like say
Kathleen Sebelius or Rod Blagojevich who
end up kinda leading on certain
national issues.
She hasn't been like that. She's all
Alaska, all the time.
I mean you could argue that her energy
policy has been influential outside
of Alaska in some ways, but
I'm not convinced. Although she is very
popular in Alaska.
Nerdfighters, particularly Republican nerdfighters, I'm interested to know what you
think about the Palin pick. Let me know in comments.
Hank, don't forget to be awesome, and as
always best wishes!
Oh! and, Hank, the nerdfighters finished the second
part of the scavenger hunt. I already did one
live blog TV show, but I'm gonna do another
one today at 3:30 p.m, Eastern.
Link in the sidebar.